it's time for our scene and unseen
segment where we reveal the stories
behind the headlines and for that we
turn to Fox News contributor Raymond
Arroyo all right Raymond you and I are
so excited because Biden is expected to
announce his re-election campaign
tomorrow as Don Lemon announced in his
Swan Song
I was in Biden about to make it official
we are expecting a campaign-style video
announcement to drop on Tuesday edits
are now being made on a video we are
told our White House team reporting that
he reported at least parts of this video
uh two weekends ago
now Laura the first question is why
can't the president do a re-election
announcement live and why does it take
weeks to record it okay tonight we have
secured something so special video of
some of the president's attempts at his
relaunch watch this
is hot
America is a nation
that can be defined in a single word
excuse me I got a little frog in my
throat we know that there's no there's
no such there's
there's so much more to finish the job
more than half of the women on my
Administration are women you lost your
child
you lost your child it's gone there's no
such thing as someone else's child our
nation's children are all our children
look um if you if it holds near and dear
to you that you uh
um like to be able to
anyway we're ready to get a lot done we
got it
Laura he may need some of those rock
stars he parades in and out of the White
House to make an appearance in his
announce now obviously that is our spoof
but it may not be far off from his real
attempts I mean everything looks like
messages from the Rest Home you know hey
Mr Biden sit up let's take a picture for
home let's say hi tell them you're doing
fine well Raymond the sad thing here is
that they've been doing this for years
editing him down and repackaging his
words
there's the bike video that's that's so
that's so cruel Raymond first of all I
think he should recreate that scene
with the what was that Tommy the red in
the back what was that scene when he
when he stood there and it looked like a
Star Wars yeah in Philadelphia oh
weren't that weird Philadelphia outside
Constitution hall right he should
recreate that because that was so
powerful and so and bring the Easter
Bunny bring the Easter Bunny yeah
exactly all that yeah well we'll bring
him back all the hits look even The
Wider media are now concerned about
Biden's age
age a big concern he'd be 82 upon being
sworn in for a second term if he wins
America's oldest president would stay in
office until he is 86 years old a lot of
Americans say frankly they're not
comfortable with that most Americans
don't want to vote for an 81 year old
man for president they'd like to go to
the Next Generation Well you know Laura
this is why they're doing this as a
pre-packaged announcement they want to
avoid the stumbles the bumbles they'll
edit it down it'll be clean and it's a
narrative that they can tell without
question and without any unexpected
missteps
and Raymond maybe they should just have
Dylan Mulvaney do it for him I mean that
kind of defines their whole or zelinski
zielinski and Dylan Mulvaney should do
it together that would be
yeah bring them all back today the
president met with the so-called
Tennessee three Laura though state
legislators who led Iraqis protest in
the state house and were disciplined for
it
so well what the Republican legislature
did was shocking it was undemocratic and
it was um
without any pressure
turn it around very quickly
I love how he's reading from the notes
well they turned it around all right
Laura by creating insensitive theatrical
moments with kid-sized coffins in the
state house and the President should
have turned it around today at the White
House not by hosting these three
grandstanding politicians but the three
families of the slain Nashville children
or the families of the three adult slain
this was Shameless today Raymond Raymond
it's like it's all stunts no substance
at all we said we did that angle years
ago and did he actually say you all
speak so well did he say that
it's like when he Cal Denise say Obama
was like clean and articulate or
something this guy is a walking
malapropism awkward and so when you have
a man married to his cheat sheet Laura
everybody speaks well finally there's a
growing Tick-Tock Trend called quit talk
where workers are no longer quietly
quitting but they're doing it out loud
for everybody to see honestly Anna I
just gotta be honest
I think I'm gonna head out too I just
don't think that this job is for me so I
am quitting
I'm and I'm quitting right now
I'm dead ass serious
you know Laura this is so sad to see
this is you know because of tick-tock
gen Z is basically teaching itself that
if you have any discomfort at work you
should just quit and they're
broadcasting it so it becomes almost
trendy and fun there was a time when
people would just call their parents or
friends to complain about work these
people are now doing it in public and
it's going to end very badly well right
Raymond what's odd about this is like do
people not have to pay bills or I mean
we didn't have the luxury of doing it we
all had to work I mean I don't
understand there's like a war on work
work is now uncle I don't understand
this like you do have to pay your bills
buildings are empty yeah well they're
killing their own cities the people the
left loves the cities and they're
killing the cities uh Raymond awesome
but I miss you not being in the same
Studios with you soon next week it's
next week exactly good to see you hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else